Jorge Ramos is a Univision anchor he
just wrote a book it's called this
called stranger the challenge of a
Latino immigrant in the Trump era he
joins the story thanks for coming on I
took I great to be here again thank you
thank you so much and congratulations on
the book and the book thank you hardly
about what American policies ought to be
we're talking about what America's
policies ought to be on the show and so
in light of that I want to ask you about
a tweet that you just sent out which I
was amazed by he was in Spanish but
here's where the tweet said I got my
voter credential to vote from the United
States in the elections in Mexico on
July 1st now I have to register and wait
for my ballot by mail it's an expensive
and complicated process but you have to
do it I thought you were an American I
am Mexican and I am American that's
completely illegal and I wish I could
give you an easier explanation on my
identity but that's exactly who I am
and I was born in Mexico I became a US
citizen and that's why I have the chance
to do that and I feel very proud of
being from Mexico and very proud from ok
there's nothing wrong with being from
Mexico I agree with that completely
what's wrong is that when you became the
citizen you took this following oath
this was a pledge and you said you swore
absolutely and entirely to renounce all
allegiance to any foreign state you have
ever been a citizen of you took that
oath but you're voting in a foreign
election how does that I'm voting in
Mexico and I'm voting here in the around
the States and there's absolutely
nothing wrong some countries allow that
and that's precisely why I have a u.s.
passport and I'm not the only one and I
think I can participate fully in the
u.s. electorally and I can do exactly
the same thing I think a lot of our
viewers may not know that you can vote
in a foreign election because again and
your to show ID happening in Europe and
is happening with the world that was not
only Mexico in the u.s. watching
it's not he's not invading at the US and
we're not at work that's the last time I
tried invading the United States and yet
Mexican citizens live in this country
vote in Mexican elections and then write
books telling Americans like me how we
should run our government when you
clearly haven't renounced your loyalty
to a foreign government why should I
take you seriously I happen to be also a
US citizen and sometimes and that's
precisely the title of the book
sometimes I do feel like a stranger
because it seems as as you as you just
pointed out that for many Americans I'm
not American enough and believe it's not
about Mexico it could be any country but
why should I take you seriously as an
American if you are still tied to a
country despite the oath you took
apparently disingenuously to renounce
your ties that country you're weighing
in a foreign election what in what sense
are you throwing there now it seems
early okay well just because of my
arguments and just because I'm a US
citizen just as you are
so so so now it seems so it seems that I
cannot complain about Donald Trump being
the most anti-immigrant president simply
because I'm asking why I should take you
seriously and our viewers decided their
view on that but let me ask you about
the story that we just played here you
have someone who has been charged by
authorities with homicide and fleeing
the scene of a homicide and federal
authorities say this guy's in the
country illegally nobody disputes that
and the city of Denver decides to let
him go on a very small bond
why wouldn't they call the federal
government why would they prevent the
federal government from enforcing
federal law well the way you presented
the story is I don't know what you want
to become state media talker because you
are criminalizing all immigrants doing
no question okay this is this is the
argument the argument is that the vast
majority of immigrants thank you for
this argument the vast majority
immigrants are not criminals in our
enforcement officer I'm just noting that
this guy has been charged in our country
with homicide and the authorities in
Denver for political reasons under
pressure from people like you have
decided that they're not going to turn
him over to the feds and now he walks
free why should I as an American citizen
be happy about that argument so I wish I
could have that that influence but so
the argument is about sanctuary cities
that's what you campaign right that's
what you don't want well I mean that
nobody else wants to defend why this guy
he's charged with homicide people in
Denver don't care about theoretical
arguments about trumping mean to
immigrants they don't want a guy charged
with homicide criminals I'm not here to
defend criminals but just to criminalize
all the immigrant population simply
because of one person would be like if I
would criminalize okay okay of course I
agree with that
you should never attack people on the
basis of things other people did of
course but I'm not talking about all
people I'm talking about this person who
was protected by policies that you
support and have advocated for and the
rest of us are suffering because of that
so why don't you tell me why it's a good
idea to let this specific guy out of
jail mister neck tattoo charged with
homicide and
why should we be happy about that they
could have turned them over to the feds
because of pressure from you again I'm
not here defending any criminals but I
think it's a good idea I think somebody
has to defend immigrants you know
American citizen let me give you let me
give you another assignment I've been
listening to what's happening in Los
Angeles it's also sensitive and the Los
Angeles Police Chief Charlie Beck said
the following that the reports of sexual
assault and domestic violence in the
city Latinos from residence has declined
why because of fear and then he said the
following at which i think is very
powerful he said imagine a young woman
imagine your daughter your sister your
mother not reporting because they are
afraid abundance increased 10% in within
populations so this is happening this is
class in college and you should have
come because you would have known that's
not a real one anyway all right thank
you for joining us I hope you'll come
back and congrats on the book